annabelle bonjour alors qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire de l'atmosphère
sur place à 7 heures à écouter une
atmosphère bon enfant ici sur cette
place du trocadéro qui réunit plusieurs
milliers de manifestants alors parmi eux
on retrouve des journalistes bien sûr
des militants associatifs des avocats et
des filets jaunes on vous l'avait dit et
tous et bien se réunissent pour dire non
à la loi sécurité globale et cet article
24 ans qui fait couler beaucoup d'encre
1 puisqu'il puni de 45000 euros d'amendé
d'un an d'emprisonnement toute personne
qui est bien diffusé des images de
policiers ou de gendarmes alors avec
nous tu as boivent ce journaliste
militant associatif et puis c'est la
main sans qui la sphère benalla n'aurait
jamais existé pas bonjour alors dites
nous pourquoi est ce qu'il est important
aujourd'hui est bien de manifester
cette loi est ce qu est ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui bah merci
moi je suis ici pour reg reporter en
colère c'est un collectif qui a été
créée il ya maintenant deux ans pour les
reporters justement on a noté depuis
deux ans une augmentation des entraves à
la liberté de la presse notamment sur le
terrain notamment dans les mouvements
sociaux
ça passe de la main sur le smartphone
sur la caméra à l'interpellation aux
violences et donc on a créé ce collectif
parce que voilà on a tout un tas de
confrères et consoeurs qui allait au
travail avec la boule au ventre
donc on s'est dit voilà il faut
s'organiser aujourd'hui avec cette loi
c'est entériné officialiser ces
pratiques là avec le nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre c'est pouvoir voir
faire des sommations à des journalistes
à interpeller des journalistes et
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus seulement
uniquement une
des marginaux ou ou quelques-uns
quelques journalistes on appelle
militants qui se faisait interpeller
c'est des journalistes des chaînes
mainstream on a ce journaliste de france
3 qui s'est fait arrêté mardi lors de la
manifestation devant l'assemblée
nationale
et donc c'est extrêmement important de
se mobiliser contre cette fois puisque
le droit à l'information c'est pas
seulement un droit corporatistes et pas
seulement un droit des journalistes est
un droit des citoyens c'est à dire que
le droit d'être informés le droit
d'informer cet article 24 il a été
modifiée le gouvernement fin précise il
a ajouté une note
donc ces diffusions malveillantes ça va
toujours pas malgré la modification de
cet article ça n'a aucun sens c'est un
prétexte parce que les appels à la haine
contre les policiers et contre quiconque
d'ailleurs c'est déjà prévu dans le code
pénal et et d'un par ailleurs cet
article 24 revoit à la baisse les peines
en cas d'appel à la haine contre des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique puisque dans le code pénal
on prévoit des peines beaucoup plus
forte donc si vous voulez c'est un
prétexte puisque la vérité c'est vouloir
dissuader les journalistes les reporters
les citoyens de pouvoir filmer aussi
donner un blanc-seing finalement aux
policiers avec une mauvais qu'ils ont
une mauvaise compréhension la loi déjà
maintenant avant que la loi parce qu'ils
pensent qu'on n'a pas dans des films et
qui pense qu'on n'a pas droit de
diffuser des images qui empêche déjà des
citoyens de filmer donc si vous voulez
ça c'est un prétexte puisque ça ne
protège ni les journalistes ne protège
ni les policiers ça va créer encore plus
de tension et ça va créer un corpus
sentiment cette fracture entre la pop et
la police et la population
la police est un service public on doit
pouvoir le regarder on voir le film et
on a pour le critiquer on peut ne même
ne pas l'aimer
en tout cas c'est un devoir des citoyens
de pouvoir observer l'action publique et
avec cette loi
et bien voilà on transforme ce service
public en un service contre le public
donc il faut poursuivre la mobilisation
elle va durer jusqu'à quand cette
mobilisation ce que vous réclamez
clairement ce qu'on réclame c'est le
retrait total de l'article 20 août et le
retrait total de la sécurité globale
parce qu'en réalité c'est un modèle de
société qu'on nous propose c'est un
modèle de surveillance de masse
c'est-à-dire les caméras de surveillance
les drones
pas seulement pour l'antiterrorisme
parce qu'on en profite de cette
situation de l'antiterrorisme pour faire
passer ça mais c'est aussi c'est que
sécurité publique pour faire du
renseignement
il ya très peu de garde-fous qui ont été
mis en place notamment sur ses articles
là on va pouvoir filmer les lieux
privatifs
on va pouvoir filmer
un certain nombre de choses avec on a
non pas on n'a pas exclu en plus
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale pour ces nounous pour ces procès
et pour les caméras mobiles et pour les
drones
donc voilà on rentre dans un autre
modèle de société qui est autre chose
qu'une démocratie et donc nous on
demande le retrait total de cette fois
puisque de toute façon il n'ya même pas
eu d'étude d'impact ça ne trouve même
pas que ça va protéger plus la
population
là les policiers je crois que ça va
juste créer encore plus de défiance à
encore plus de méfiance est donc nous on
est content c'est toi pour le retrait de
cette loi et aussi pour le retrait du
nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
qui permet aujourd'hui d'interpeller des
journalistes qui font leur travail sur
des mouvements sociaux
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste vous
même et puis à l'origine on le rappelle
de cette affaire banale à s'enfuir avec
cette loi si elle passe on aura plus
jamais d'affaires benalla envers on
n'aura plus jamais l'occasion enfin de
voir deux images de violences policières
aussi cessé et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
se mobiliser contre toi tu es merci à
taboye half ton que vous l'avez entendu
un est à bouafles sait bien qui a
dénoncé une loi est liberticide un
l'entièreté de cette loi sécurité
globale et bien ils demandent le retrait
comme bien ces milliers de manifestants
rassemblés 6 place du trocadéro merci
beaucoup on allège pour toutes ces
précisions nadège abderrazak en direct
de la place du trocadéro à paris on vous
retrouvera bien sûr tout au long de
l'après-midi lors de nos prochaines
éditions